hey guys Lucy here on the game swathi 3
2015 stage I am joined by Dan Pinchbeck
creative director on everybody's gone to
the rapture and you know what done we
have the game like I could see it on the
screen let's get it straight in there
because it just sure let's do it lutely
gorgeous thank you very much I'm from
England I have spent time in Shropshire
so why have you chosen trophy I mean
it's a beautiful beautiful place but as
a as a setting for your game it's really
beautiful it's um I just sort of seemed
to have that natural kind of like
combination of the kind of like rural
isolated bit of a sort of like it just
was England you know we're kind of like
we want to make if we're going to set
this in England in 1984 we've got to
find somewhere that just feels like
what's the most English English place we
can get to we did a lot of looking round
little bit of driving did a bit of
looking a went to know what it's
Shropshire just singling with a capital
e and it just felt completely right so
and we can see I mean if you wanna I do
if you want to start wandering around
but it's kind of its suburban I mean
there is no other way of saying it is
just so English is so English of when I
was obviously I lived in the city but
when when you'd go visit like my sister
lived in her in a place that was pretty
much identical to those as a referee we
start the game scissor I put the the
valise Observatory which is it seems to
be the center something the whole
thing's like it's an open-world
story-driven miska drain mystery game
really so dumb to play room without
really telling him anything about you
you find it it's fine your beer I mean
what is the the backstory here and there
literally we don't really have any
backstory for the player where you go in
apart from it's 1984 it's the end of the
world something terrible's happened off
you go go explore shrine right now we're
really kind of like looking for players
to just engage with the story gets
sucked into the stories of the people
and the characters they find and all the
time you got this kind of underlying
mystery of of whatever did happen and
really it's it's it's pretty open we
wanted not hand hold as much as we can
that's wonderful I mean because I
suppose that's the thing isn't it
because in most modern games you know
press X to jump do this do this to her
and it's relentless but in a game like
this it's just kind of freedom yeah we
really wanted to do that we
really like the idea of kind of evolving
away from where we started with games
like dear Esther where story different
games tend to be very linear he tend to
just move along in the story drops in
front of you we thought well it's not
like really interesting and really cool
if we just go we'll look there's a world
for the story here but we're not gonna
tell you where it is we're not really
going to help you find it just go and
make your own story out the pieces we
give you and we don't have to do the
usual open world kind of you have a very
open world you have linear missions
within it really is extraordinarily open
and it's down to you too kind of join
all those pieces together and make
everything make sense oh so what are you
doing here so around the valley we have
these these strange phenomena that you
find and when you come across and we're
using the the tilt on the ds4 to tune in
like you're tuning in an analog radio
and if you find the right frequency than
in lot B sort of memories and pieces of
what's happened which gives you all
these kind of clues and let you know
about the characters that are around and
then while these are happening there's
no cutscenes you're still moving around
you can find your own camera position so
these are these characters are quite
static in this scene but if you find
them in other places they'll start
moving around they won't wait for you
they'll just go ahead carry on their
lives and how much you pay attention to
that whether you stay join in with the
story whether you just wander off is
completely up to you and that's really
nice because it means out of all the
characters in the community of the
valley you can find the people that
interests you most and then follow their
stories you're not limited to just kind
of following one plot as you go through
so do do they maybe mention like an area
that they're going to go to or do you
literally just follow them the entire
way though yeah well you can you can
follow them around so there's there's
six major areas in the game which
respond sir I'm just waiting for the the
scene to finishing the lights to turn
back on here so i can tell you down into
the village the six big areas need each
area you find a story about one of the
main characters but they're not limited
to that area so the stories get back to
forwards the whole mystery takes place
over four days so people will just go
about the valley and the places where
they are so if Stephen says like I'm
going off to the camp if you happen to
be in the camp at the right time you'll
see what he did there so so I'm gonna
fall right on to have a day-night cycle
two things change depending on time
there's not a day/night cycle because
it's more tied into what happened when
so although the the as you progress
through the game the weather progresses
the time progresses it's not like
cycling through we did have that in
originally and then we found it because
we jumping backwards and forwards in
time anyway when you threw that in over
the top
but people just like one literally no
idea now what's going on so mean let's
talk a minute about the visuals because
this is stunning see dear Esther was
made in source yes engine and this is
CryEngine four yeses CryEngine which is
a amazing engine to work in for this
kind of these fabulous sweet CryEngine 3
that's right yeah i mean how have you
managed to make a world that's kind of
so realistic looking a lot of time in a
lot of research we have them we got
walls in the office it's like a Carrie
Bradshaw's mad wall in homeland which is
like thousands of pictures up of English
countryside an awful lot of research and
of course we're trying to sort of do our
best to make sure everything's dated
accurately yeah so we had things like in
the fields like we had to look up we've
got to amazing places like world silage
did they wrap hay bales in 1984 what if
pylons look like in 1984 and these are
questions that need to be answered them
but I've never actually thought of sorry
and I'm never actually thought of that I
mean no well I mean and you can't you
have to mean players it's what I love
back the game community they really care
about this stuff I catch you out we've
had quite a lot of people come back
about the petrol station saying your
petrol prices are on for 1984 we've had
to go back no it's gallons not liters
you know it's it's all had to have a lot
of thought and a lot of attention going
into it I mean we just went past there a
red phone box yes sadly disappearing
from the British country we really
missed them so yeah it's nice to be able
to go back into an England that kind of
still has those features I mean look at
that pop I mean you could go past that
haha we can go into the pub oh wait
original EU couldn't and uh one of our
artists rich he went away at a weekend
of mates of pub interiors he said you
can't have an English pub game without
being able to well being able to head in
go in and they've got the yard of a oler
oh yeah I'll with the day we got fish
and chips they're mean it's just they
don't amazing job we're so lucky the
team are absolutely fantastic they're so
passionate and there they young and
there's there's so few them in this 15
people have made this game which for the
scale of it and yeah the way it looks is
really quite extraordinary so 50p for a
pine 15 yeah good grief I'm an art team
of between four and five people at any
given time so they've done amazingly in
three of them it's their first job out
of college so they've really just it's
exceptional what they come up with so
talking abou idea I still obviously
Chinese rooms for
game uh have you I can't have you
wandering around there wasn't really
much traditional gameplay and it's
always the game that comes up in the
discussions of what is a game what it is
our games are I mean what is yours words
to that I think it just there's so many
games now whatever your taste is
whatever game you want to play a game
exists we should just be celebrating
that that's to me is why the game
industry is so awesome we shouldn't be
saying well you can't do this or you can
i'll do that we stuff every single time
someone does something that bends the
rules a bit i'll break somebody does
something different we should be
standing up and like just just cheering
him on so if it's not your type of game
that's fine play something different I
mean I'm a huge huge shooter fan it was
mainly what I play and it's kind of nice
to make something very different to that
but yeah that's diversity is great
diversity can only ever be a good thing
we should just celebrate it so it
doesn't really bother me if people go is
it a game you go well if you think it's
a game you want to play a game it's a
game go great enjoy it you know so we're
just wandering a little bit around this
beautiful town interruption right now so
high so I mean it can reminds you a lot
have gone home which is I'm sure a
comparison you get a lot yeah it was
kind of nice that you know kind of dear
Esther then gone home then it's moved
into things like a drift we've had eat
the one it really feels like there's
kind of a burgeoning genre appearing but
like the games are becoming more complex
they're becoming more interesting that
whole thing of kind of walking simulator
if you just walk along and gets told to
you really i think most of these games
have moved beyond that now which is
incredibly exciting so yeah we're really
proud stand shoulder to shoulder with ya
and it has a real strong vibe of the
vanishing of Ethan Carter as well yeah
absolutely the game went similarly your
punked in a world that one gives you a
bit of exposition though that you're but
this is just kind of the pure gameplay
thing yeah so we don't mean originally
we had sort of firm like with the the
tilt mechanism we had been there are
more complex they require kind of like
almost like unlocking a phone with your
finger and when we still have put it
started putting in front of people they
were coming back and going but I just
want to get at the story and I don't
wanna have to be worrying about this and
I go from like being in the world into
like puzzle-solving mode so we ended up
putting a lot of that stuff back and
just going to top people here for the
story they want the story let's just
get out any HUD get any puzzles and just
put you as close into the world as we
can as close into the storage account
and it seems that's really what people
have kind of engaged with and wanted so
much so which is great as a writer you
know people going I don't want anything
in the way the story are going all cool
that means I did a good job I say I mean
how do you sort six characters that Wiz
being character game over all six of
them are kind of like major characters
do you follow through these six areas
and uh yeah but there's what's really
nice is again people really sort of
latch on to smaller characters whatever
and the team's got their favorite
character and they're not always the big
carrots and when people are playing it
what we're really interested when the
kind of game goes live when people play
it is saying well who do you who do you
identify with who the people you really
like and we try to really make them feel
like real people a real community so
we're hoping that people people play
they'll stay I know these people I live
with them I'm friends with them I'm
related to them that makes it mean
something when you're kind of going so
this is the end of the world it's not
some kind of like abstract thing this is
something happening to people that we
recognize it's happening to us and
that's really important I think to it
it's also a very strange not strange but
I mean when you typically think of end
of the world you think uh you think you
were game like fallout you know the
barren wastelands you think of the color
brown you don't think of a lush British
countryside yeah we really like that
that it feels like really different but
it has this this great kind of eerie
Mary Celeste thing where you go along
and there's like you find a cigarette
that's been half smoked you find coffee
still steaming and it really makes you
it sets up that tone of did I just miss
this when did this happen and am I going
to sort of come around a corner what am
I going to find and it makes it really
interesting and it's just for us i think
it's we grew up Jess and I in kind of
light in the 80s and the tail end of the
Cold War and it was you know you have
this amazing vehicle setting we would
terrify the nuclear bombs we're going to
go off you know there was complete
social panic about AIDS there were
strikes going off left right and center
and we wanted to play against that kind
of really bucolic beautiful English
countryside that underlying tension of
know something really bad has happened
to I think you feel more of that tension
because it's so beautiful because it's
not you're not looking at a ruined
landscape you're going well how can
something really bad have happened here
if it looks and sounds so gorgeous if it
seems on the surface everything's fine
yeah at this bit just how whatever
happened just happened
minutes ago really is that minutes ago
that's a question that's part of the
mystery know when did this happen and
and how long has it been and how long
have you been here and there all the
questions that we want the player to
really get into an answer and from a
writing perspective was it kind of easy
to come up with these characters in this
scenario um how do you money I mean
aboard with you know loads of red string
going from people to people it kind of
was I mean we started with the
characters and we really worked on the
basis of saying if we create a really
believable community full of characters
that people really like and engage with
then that's most of the work and then we
can go and say ok well now we understand
Rachel's character we know what she's
like we know as she react right let's
put Rachel in this situation and then as
a writer your then kinda gay it's almost
like writing for soap opera yeah where
you're not going plot what plot all the
way you're going we take people that you
want to discover about you want to find
out what happened to them if you get
that the writing kind of ven falls from
there and then the big challenge was
then it was technically balancing it
going right okay so it makes it the
village at four o'clock on tuesday she
can't be in the industrial estate at
five o'clock on tuesday she's going to
take at least two hours to get there but
she's supposed to meet Steven over by
the laundrette at three o'clock Metzger
backwards and Portugal so i'll make its
all the scenes were in the right place
so all that kind of like logic made sure
that it added up and stopped because
again players are smart players will get
all that sort of stuff and we really
wanted to say yeah you know this the
story goes deep there's an awful lot of
detail so even though is something which
is mechanically not so complicated it
should appeal to kind of like quite
hardcore kind of RPG players and you
know i grew up playing kind of like mind
forever voyaging and text-based
adventures and we really wanted to say
this is a modern text-based adventure
this is how you can still do that kind
of really story-driven adventure worlds
we can do it incredibly kind of high end
graphics and an audio and music I stand
when can we finally get our hands on
everybody's going to throw at you it
comes out on august eleventh on the PSN
store not long at all along at all we're
really over there and mar we so thank
you so much for joining me i'm afraid
that's all we have time for make sure
you don't go anywhere guys because we've
got more coverage here from e3 2015
right here on the game sports stage stay
away well thank you
you